Some of the oldest people alive today drink
a glass of wine or eating two strips of bacon
every morning.
Which doesn’t sound half bad.. but how can
we really live longer?
Hey everyone!
Julia here for DNews
While genes are a big factor into living longer,
genetics only make up 30% of the story.
The rest seems up to us.
Life expectancy at birth in the U.S. has been
rising for all groups at rate of about .6
years a year.
People born in the last five years could reasonably
expect to live into their late 70s even early
80s.
At this rate, it seems like we could live
until 100 soon!
Well, not quite yet.
Most researchers thought that living longer
meant more time doing what you love.
The assumption just went without saying.
However recent research showed otherwise.
Scientists at University of Massachusetts
Medical School extended the life of roundworm
by playing with four different mechanisms.
No matter what mutations they had, the worms
lived longer, but they spent a greater percentage
of their live in a frail state.
BUMMER DUDE.
As we extend our lifespans with modern medicine,
age related diseases like Alzheimer's and
certain cancers are on the rise.
We seem to be extending the amount of time
we spend in suffering.
To spend more time healthy, that’s going
to take some heavy scientific lifting.
Researchers from UCLA showed that by turning
on a single gene they could extend life by
30%.
AMP-activated protein kinase helps get rid
of cellular garbage by promoting autophagy,
or destroying sick or damaged cells.
The story goes that over time our cells get
damaged as we age and it’s the build up
of these damaged cells that lead to age related
illnesses.
The enzyme helps the body clean up all these
damaged cells.
The researchers found that flies who had this
gene activated lived up to 30% longer and
were healthier during their later days.
Yet note that I said flies, this hasn’t
been proved in mammals yet.
Another way to boost your lifespan?
Caloric Restriction.
For some reason rats who are fed shockingly
low number of calories, live up to 40% longer
than their peers.
Scientists think a lack of glucose is responsible.
Glucose occasionally binds to some of our
DNA, proteins and lipids, and stops them from
doing their jobs causing some disease.
A restricted diet might prevent some of this
process.
But there’s no evidence this works in humans
and it’s not recommended, for obvious reasons.
Rather than starving yourself, could you pop
a pill?
One FDA approved drug, Rapamycin, already
extends the lifespan and healthspan in mice
by 30%.
But unfortunately it’s designed as an immunosuppressant.
Knocking out your immune system could be a
pretty heavy price to pay for a chance at
a longer life.
Yet recent research is working on blocking
the immunosuppressant qualities.
And you can’t talk about immortality without
talking about telomeres.
Telomeres are like the plastic tips on your
shoelaces, but for your DNA.
Everytime DNA makes a copy of itself, the
telomeres get shorter.
If they weren’t there at all, your DNA would
fray like a shoelace and cause age-related
diseases.
So what would happen if we could stop telomere
shortening?
Most of these possibilities only seem to extend
lifespan 10-30 years, which is not forever.
But hey, I’ll take it.
Geneticist Richard Cawthon thinks if we could
get rid of all aging processes and repair
cellular damage, humans could live up to 1,000
years.
The question is - would you want to?
What do you think?
let us know in the comments and keep coming
back here for more DNews every day of the
week!